if you're looking for ways to find
fulfillment change your story and own
your business then this video is for you
what's gonna fulfill you is differently
at first and actually you're not gonna
learn that from anybody else you got to
find it because success without
fulfillment is the ultimate failure the
middle of my do is I want to know more
about my clients than anybody that may
know about themselves and I see ya and
how many times the science shows
something's impossible now science shows
as possible things are impossible till
somebody does it need motivation watch a
top 10 with believe nation what's up
it's Evan my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe in that amazing
gift you have inside you that I want to
see come out so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
on today's lessons from a man who went
from having seven fathers growing up and
having to leave home at age 17 due to an
abusive home environment to found the
companies that have now over six billion
dollars in annual revenue and advises
presidents he's Tony Robbins and here's
my take on his top ten rules to success
volume three
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one find fulfillment fulfillment
is an art what's going to fulfill you is
differently a person next you're not
gonna learn that from anybody else you
got to find it because success without
fulfillment is the ultimate failure and
I get those phone calls all the time for
the multi billionaire entrepreneur or
politician or business person or person
just one there Academy Award and they're
depressed and they can't tell anybody
because they got all their goals but
they're not fulfilled because they
really don't have that sense of meaning
in their life they went for something
and they got it they achieved and if you
doubt this what I'm saying is relevant
to you or us or anyone just think about
about a year and what a month ago we
lost what I consider be a national
treasure robbing wipes how many of you
loved robbing wipes look around they
don't keep me handsome look and most of
you didn't know him almost anywhere you
go in the world people love Robin wings
by the way was he graded achievement oh
my god that guy he said he want to make
become a great comedian he did that I
want to make the world laugh he did I
want to make my own TV show he did I
wanted the number one TV show he did it
I want to make movies he did I want an
Academy Award for not being funny not
his skill set drama and he did it I want
a beautiful family he did it and then he
hung himself make everybody happy but
yourself
not a good plan so if I had a gift to
give you it would be maybe make a
different decision and a decision is
that no matter what happens in your life
you're gonna live in a beautiful state a
beautiful state and that could be happy
that could be grateful that could be
being generous those are all beautiful
states aren't they could be curious it
could be fun it could be playful you're
not limited to one state but it's
different than suffering and most people
suffering and all suffering I've ever
seen I've traveled 100 countries I've
dealt with presidents of countries and
you know presidents of businesses CEOs
I've dealt with people in prison I dealt
with you name average people suffering
always comes because you've obsessed
about something related to you you can
only be depressed if you're focusing on
yourself so now I'm depressed cos my
kids and and they're not doing well no
you're depressed because you feel you've
failed your kids it's about you it's
about how you think you what you should
have done or shouldn't have done or what
someone did to you or didn't do to you
in the past through the future which
don't even exist so I have a simple goal
my goal is help people make a decision
that says I don't know what's gonna
happen you might get a divorce even
though you don't think so you might find
a family of your family with cancer you
might have your house get burned down or
have a tornado go by and if you live in
the same place that happens every two
years and you move back we should talk
but some people seem to do that for some
reason you can't control those things I
can't control those things I don't want
those to happen to you or anybody I love
or anybody who's even a stranger to me
but they're going to happen true not
positive thinking both just the truth so
if that's gonna happen I say make a
decision now that says I'm gonna live in
a beautiful state and I'm gonna find
beauty and whatever Life brings me cuz
life is too short not to I love this as
an opener the first stop that came to
mind is man Tony is just a huge guy
sitting on seat you just so much bigger
than everybody else and the other thing
that comes to mind is just you have to
enjoy the work you're doing to like you
find fulfillment in the day-to-day not
in achieving the outcome it's not about
hitting 10 million subscribers on
YouTube it's about this is of making
another videos but enjoying the process
of life of the work of your career of
the relationship and not just hidden
arbitrary goals that don't in themselves
have any meaning so thank you Tony for
the great lead moving on the rule number
2 feed your mind with greatness I think
I'm gonna like this one so what do you
think was the first real breakthrough
that you had as a team that started you
on your path and how did you get there
gosh there's so many other one of the
first ones I think was probably just
anchoring in when my mom and my dad I
ported fathers my mom was a powerful
woman so she kicked my fourth father out
whose name I carry and he adopted me and
when he went out she decided was in his
side so she kicked me out too by chasing
me out with a knife and I wasn't worried
she's gonna stab
or anything but I decided this is
freedom I've got to find a way to make
my life work but I had no money out of
1960 Volkswagen I worked forty dollars a
week as a janitor to buy and pay for and
so I had no car and no money I don't
know anything
I went slept in a person's laundry room
and then I decided I've got to figure
out what to do and I needed a feed my
money because I was so depressed I was
so overwhelmed I'm missing my brother
and sister and feeling just completely
out of sorts so I I got on the bus and I
traveled 14 miles a member because I
have running at one time and I was in
this book store and I bought this book
called the magic of believing my quad
head crystals the first real book other
than maybe thinking go rich or Emerson's
essays and I started on this journey of
saying every single day I'm gonna feed
my mind I'm not going to hope good
thoughts show up I'm gonna read
biographies I'm gonna I'm gonna find out
what makes people tick I'm gonna
understand what makes me tick and I
wanted to read a book a day but I didn't
do that click to the speed reading class
and I read seven books over seven years
and they're all personal development
human development psychology physiology
and what I try to do is take anything
that I learned and apply it and then
when I applied it you know I was 5-1 in
my sophomore in high school I'm six
seven now I tell people differences
personal growth but sincerely I became
mister solution because I wanted to help
everybody so I was this little fat guy
and I couldn't lose weight and I lost
weight all my buddies are like how'd you
do that I said well here's what I did
they lost weight man we all got girls
and as a young kid you know that led to
where you know if you have a problem I
was mister solution specially if your
girl has more motivated energy so the
breakthrough was really understanding
the power of compressing decades in the
days if someone has spent decades of
their life and they compress it into a
book and you can read it in an hour or a
few days you have such an advantage
because when you learn by your own
experience it's painful and it's slow
when you learn about other people's
experience everybody knows in the
financial world other people's money is
elaborate right well other people's
experience is more powerful in other
people's money
because you can have the money and lose
it but if you give the experience you
can change it all so I think that was
the beginning for me and it set me on
on path of hire and I've never lost my
hunger this is at the core of what I do
and why I do it
I wanted to surround myself with
greatness daily with video because I
like video a lot more than reading or
listening to things podcast I wanted to
wake up and every day I had a place that
God I could reliably go to to get new
information to feed my mind with
greatness did I have to think about it
every day and I created that for you
guys too you can wake up load a new
video and boom there it is something new
to feed your mind with greatness and you
just can't help it if you are hanging
around Tony Robbins and Steve Jobs and
these characters every single day the
way they think the way they blow through
lemonade beliefs the way they don't
accept the status quo will seep into you
the help you become a better you it just
will happen and so the more you can
surround yourself with greatness great
minds people that push you motivate you
the more you're gonna grow I'm loving
the first two so far let's move the rule
number three own your business the
minimum I do is I'd want to know more
about my clients than anybody then they
know about themselves I know a man that
from Australia decided he's a dentist
and he decided he was tired of people
not showing up he was tired of trying to
bill and not getting paid you know
properly there's insurance said he was
tired all these things one day he just
decided to sit down with everyone was
patients 101 and he said I'm changing my
practice I'm gonna practice where I'm
gonna take a lot less clients and let go
probably have two clients laugh right
now I only want to do business with
people who I personally like who when
they come in I want to sit down have a
cup of tea with them well I understand
what's going on in their life what their
goals are and I want to make sure that
everything in my psyche has taken care
of them and helping them augment the way
they look the way they feel and their
vitality and the health of their system
and he sat down and said so to do that I
want you to know I have some simple
things I'm promising I'll give you the
best dental care of your entire life I'm
promising that if you come in your
appointment you will not be delayed more
maximum of five minutes ever I'm any way
that all these things will get the best
care of this this the most most
attention he goes but this is what I'm
gonna require for patients that work
with me our through not someone else
that this
companies that require that if they
cancel they're gonna have to pay for it
I require they show up on time because
I'm gonna respect them they respect me
I'm going to also require that in the
next six months that if I do the quality
work that I promise they'll give me two
referrals to other quality people that
I'd probably want to take care of as
well and he said I'm shutting down any
other form of my business and I'm gonna
spend more quality time with you and I
want the referrals because I wanna spend
time with marketing and sell a home I
spent time putting my attention and
making your life better
he quadrupled his income and cut the
time he spent doing dental work by more
than sixty percent just because he
became an owner who owned his business
instead of running around trying to
please everybody and being frustrated
people are cancelling and so forth most
of us just don't own ourselves enough
right you have to as an entrepreneur set
boundaries for yourself both in terms of
clients working with ideal clients work
with the clients who respect you will
pay you on time will refer business to
you to believe you're genuine like
working with and also from your team
people who have the skill set but also
buy into the vision the mission the
culture what you're trying to accomplish
and you'll find that most of the time
most of the headaches come from a select
few people select few customers and a
select few employees a select few
partners most of the headaches come from
a select few people eliminate those
focus on the ideal candidates and you
can go a lot further I love it when Tony
gives entrepreneur advice to extra
nuggets of gold now let's move on to
rule number four change your story when
something is considered quote/unquote
impossible how do you reframe it so it
becomes possible in your mind and how
much of that is mindset I think
impossible is not a fact it's an opinion
when someone tells me it's impossible
I always just look at anybody around me
knows that they can't do this that's
part of it but if they didn't know me
it's your opinion they'll say no science
shows and I say yeah I know how many
times the science shows something's
impossible now science shows it's
possible things are impossible till
somebody does it and so I find that you
know most of your business people you
look at businesses and what does it take
to make a business grow it's not
impossible like a business grow up has
been shrinking for a long time or it's
been stuck the real problem is always
the choke hold as always the psychology
and the skills of the leader always an
80% of that as psychology and 20% of the
mechanics like if you don't know how to
read your financials and you're trying
to fly the plane of your your company I
mean come on you know if all you do is
go down you look at profit loss and you
see what it is and you have a beer
either way you either celebrated at the
brass you know something you know you're
gonna be in trouble right but if you
have the skillsets that's one thing but
you can get any skill set if you have
the psychology and anytime a business is
not growing it is not because it's
impossible it's because they aren't
innovating and they're not innovating
because they're believing it's
impossible I mean if we all know what
does it take to transform an obviously a
people takes three things to create a
breakthrough and anything and your
personal life in your business anywhere
you need a strategy but that's not the
first place you should look at it's the
first place all of us look me too it's
our inherent thing you want to lose
weight well how do I do it I'm gonna
grow my business how do I do it it's
it's instinctively been trained to think
that way but the problem is the how-to
is usually not that complex I'm gonna
come on
70% of America is what 75% of America
now is overweight is that because it's
so complex how to be fit and strong
right you know only the 1% no the answer
is they hide it from you you have to
work your ass off to not hear what it
takes right and so so you know I
remember I went to this I went to a TED
med Center and I watched about 12
doctors wouldn't have to get up and do
these stories about if we could just get
patients to take their medications and
try to figure out the whole thing and I
was just looking and going you're all
talking about strategy you've forgotten
psychology because strategy is wonderful
I'm a strategist but my whole life
freaking out strategy is we both know a
strategy could save you a decade right
and doesn't the strategy could save you
you know it could make the devastating
success and failure but most people have
strategies available or they could get
them or you could create them but the
problem is you got a story and your
story is why it isn't working and the
story is I've tried what but everything
if you tried everything you'd be fit you
try everything you'd be profitable if
you tried everything you'd be there but
people said you know I'm big-boned
that's what I used to say I'm still big
bone but I'm
thirty-eight pounds lighter than I was
25 years ago and I've never gained it
back right a borrower's big bone that
was my story all the good ones are gone
that's why I'm not in a relationship or
they're gay and I'm not on a game they
are whatever the story is there's always
a story and what I tell people's you
know if you can just divorce the story
of your limitation and marry the truth
of your unlimited capacity then the
whole game changes I agree that mindset
is everything every major breakthrough
I've made in my life and my business has
been from changing a limiting belief
that I had I'm just realizing that
wasn't true and it's funny how often
some of the things we do were just
subconscious that we just naturally
always do it a certain way where we're
not realizing that we're holding
ourselves back and so I love it I love
the idea as soon as you find that thing
that you feel you're hooding itself back
on it's a little inkling to the truth
that you need to push hard on the fix
because through that you're gonna end up
achieving your next big goal let's go to
rule number five be obsessed with adding
value when you went off on your own you
know that's kind of the point I think
people you know most businesses fail at
the beginning in the first few years so
there you are on your own what do you
think were the keys to success those
first few years by yourself
obsession without any more value than
anybody else ever dreamed of I mean my
entire life from the very beginning days
was how do I do more for others than
anyone else on earth how do I give them
experiences that are lasting how do I
create change what change was impossible
I'm going to take something from the
therapy for seven years in an hour
produced that result and the way I did
that was by challenging traditional
psychologists and psychiatrists and
getting on national radio and saying
given you were stationed on handle in an
hour which was pretty abrasive you know
as a young kid you can get by with that
stuff but the best part was I backed it
up and so one of the first interventions
I did was in Vancouver British Columbia
Canada back on the radio and this
psychiatrist got on the phone and just
on the radio whine I'm just passionate
you are a liar you're a charlatan people
like you should not be allowed on the
radio and I said sir I said I said are
you you know scientists used to the
course of a physician I said well a
scientist would never make it an a
sumption I said you've never met me
right now you never do my clients know
you call me a liar on national
radio I said she must be saving your
hypothesis your hypothesis is that I'm a
liar miserable cannon if you're stating
hypothesis and you're truly a scientist
you gotta be willing to test it
am i right yeah yeah it's great not
doing a free guest event the Holiday Inn
tomorrow night anyone hearing my voice
can come I'm gonna do a series of
demonstrations and I'm gonna take one of
your clients and turn around I said
share with me somebody that you've never
been able to change I said I'm sure you
got plenty of those you wanna play
hardball because wait a lot of patients
aren't me to change yet I said I haven't
found any course I've done three
therapies total but I'm simply a long
story short he told me this one we've
been working on for seven years
it's what a snake phobia a phobia is not
just a fear it's a bunny control
response to fear so like she dreamed the
snake would bite her on the face and
then the adrenaline shoot through her
body and wake her up and there's enough
in four to seven times a night seven
years so you know he was put in the
corner and so he brought her down it
took me about 15 minutes at the end of
it I tested first and she's straining
and shaking and then I wrapped the snake
around her and that changed my entire
career because in that moment everything
there was no question everybody honey
Thunder this woman is transformed I said
you've been treated but that's like
nitrogen how many years then I took on
sports stars that I can't turn around
you know I think it's more my mother
Teresa Nelson Mandella Bill Clinton and
as the years went by it just built it
doesn't though so first off I love they
got his big break in Canada
go Canada second I love the business
advice a tactical entrepreneurial advice
as well business comes from successfully
creating value right the more value that
you create for somebody and more you're
gonna get paid you want to get paid
quickly provide a ton of value quickly
not everybody has the ability yet when
you first start to create amazing value
but that's the game the more value can
give somebody the more successful you're
gonna be in business it's this the
number-one rule the most important rule
abide by it
let's go to number six focus everyone in
this room knows how to create you're not
a manager of your life you're a creator
of your life or you wouldn't be in this
room how do you create your life you get
hungry for something don't you who has
done something your life that once
seemed difficult or impossible and now
it's part of your life who's got
something in your life let's say
say aye how did you do it you created it
three ways number one you decided
there's something you wanted so bad that
you unleashed all your desire you became
obsessed with it if it was a business or
a car or a relationship or a
transformation in your body if there's
something you want sin vision and now
it's real it's because you didn't just
envision it you brought so much emotion
to it then now it's in your life it was
once a dream it was once a goal and now
it's in your life
how many have something like that in
your life now say I you may take it for
granted now hopefully not but it was
once just a vision may have seemed
impossible at one time so how did you do
it you started with a concrete vision of
what you wanted and you focused on it
continuously didn't you wherever focus
goes energy flows you envision something
you got clear about it and then you
started thinking about all the reasons
why you wanted it you got excited about
it so this is what's next for me now I
want this you may have dreamed about a
thought about and talked about it but
when you focus on something continuously
something magical happens you get
insights don't you you overhear a
conversation hear something you wouldn't
have heard if you didn't have that
outcome or goal that you wanted so badly
who has ever come up with something
obsessed about it didn't even know how
to do it and it just happened and it
came together who's that that experience
say I so why don't we tap into that
power now for your business in life
again this is one of the messages that
comes up over and over and over again in
the top tens
consistency focus determination staying
with it you can be people who've been
around in business for decades because
you are putting in more work than their
because you are more focused than they
are you can get past people have more
natural talent than you because you're
putting in the work to actually get
better and you have a clear goal while
they don't so whatever it is you want to
accomplish make sure that your schedule
where your focus in your time is
matching the ambitions that you have for
yourself and your company let's move on
the rule number seven diversify the goal
if you own a business
I will soon a lot of your viewers our
business owners or for getting started
in business no matter how good you are
in business think about this the one
universal rule that idiots in finance
know is diversification if the only free
lunch you've got a diversify because if
you put all your eggs in one basket no
matter how good the basket is one day
that real estate market that stock
market that bond market that
collectibles mark whatever you invest in
right now you showed me statistically
it'll drop 50 to 70 percent on a day now
if you're later in life and that happens
it's over for you so you have to
diversify and yet most people may know
real estate so they do it or they know
stocks they do it or they grew up with
the hand their parents flipping things
and it's the wrong thing to do so you've
got to diversify in order for you to be
able to truly succeed and that's why
when you want a business yeah if you put
all your money in your business which is
what most of us do naturally you see
yeah you put all your eggs in one basket
and there's things that can happen I
mean you know you're let's say you spend
20 years and you figured out how to put
together the ultimate map you know and
you remember Garmin came out with this
thing called the TomTom honor of your
number used to get on your I would love
to remember that before anything yeah I
just put on your dash down cost 100
bucks it was a breakthrough they're
making like I'm design or something oh
yeah yeah six months later what happened
the iPhone came out we have several apps
then you put a bastards my French came
out with it put Google Maps with their
own map on here and tell us how much
zero what am I gonna do to your business
when someone takes your product deserve
it gives away for free so I always tell
people competition happens technology
happens what you must do is have a
second business we know with no moving
parts no people no time maybe it takes
you two to three days a year for two or
three hours after you've read the book
you put it in place and you measure it
two three times a year that's it yeah go
on with your life now those are trouble
in your business you're financially set
I in my life I have 31 companies now we
have you know what do we have 1200
employees seven different industries we
do five billion in sales I mean I used
to be you know me and my seminar
business it's grown geometrically but
with all those moving parts the only web
succeed is because I pick in everyone
those businesses I've diversified my
assets so that when things were in
trouble I still have enough economics
figure myself and keep the business
going so everybody needs to create a
money machine that works while you sleep
that doesn't have moving parts and
that's what this is really about this is
really the most controversial point are
the ones that have come so far there's
varying opinions on this I think of
Andrew Carnegie who was the richest man
in the world at one point and he said
put all your eggs in one basket and then
watch that basket so that you don't have
the iPhone Google map thing happened to
your industry you're always on the
cutting edge
my take I think it's important to focus
on your business I think you can easily
get too spread out and easily want to do
ten things and then none of them get
done properly but while you're focused
on your business once you start making
some money you take a little bit out
like you're saving whether it's ten
percent a year or whatever it is the
rules from Babylon you take a little bit
out and then you put it into stock
markets and you put it into other
investments that you don't necessarily
have to be an expert on you can work
with people to manage it for you but
your main focus on your business and
then every year you pull a little money
out just in case to have as a nest egg
that retirement savings that just in
case something happens you're ready to
go that's my take but I'd love to hear
what you guys think diversify go all-in
or some kind of mix let me know in the
comments why you guys are thinking about
that let's move the rule number eight
live your mission so what are the
trade-offs that you would consider like
you know we work our asses off we do a
lot of stuff but this is what we had to
sacrifice in order to do it if you think
it that way I think if you think of it
as a sacrifice
then you're gonna build frustration and
resentment
I really don't if you think it's that
question shouldn't do it I think the
challenge is that most people have this
illusion about life work balance and
that's you know if you're gonna
accomplish it's what people are laughing
is you know it's [ __ ]
right what's true is life work
integration so I was just in twenty one
country or seven countries twenty-one
days but who's with me is my family
who's with me as my friends and I've
done well enough to have a plane and
that rooms and all that kind of cool
stuff makes it but when I didn't we
still we pumped it together and
beginning days it was coach and dragging
ourselves around but
I thought it was great for my kids to
have schooling but I thought an
education was more valuable in traveling
the earth was a part of that but you
know we're in the middle of this crazy
schedule but we're it's not work it's a
mission when it's work it's that I was
asked people I said how would you
describe what you do in people I say
because at work
it's a couriers admission and most
people of course say it's work and
that's exactly what is this heavy if
it's you know if it's your career it
gives you something more but your
mission it doesn't wear you out it
brings energy to you it's fulfilling and
if you can tie your mission in with the
people that you love it's pretty cool
you know some people assume they're my
friends I see Dean here in the front row
here and it's like we're all on this
mission and we find time to connect and
be with each other and have a blast with
each other but we're sharing about
things that matter I'm not a person to
go to a party in like you know go on the
corner and chitchat it's like you want
to talk about something deep let's lock
you down let me go home and be with my
family you know let me go do something
fun without some of that nature if you
can combine your mission with your
family combine your mission with some of
your friends then you're gonna
accomplish a million times more but if
you think it's a sacrifice don't do it
because then all you're doing is you're
gonna have resentment later on or
frustration later on and and then you
really aren't contributing because it's
you're you're trading off you're not
giving I really love this point it's
hard to express how much I love this
point for people who are complaining
that they don't have time for vacation
they don't have time to do XYZ it's
integration it has to be like if you are
looking at as your business is
preventing you from doing some things
and you need to change what you're doing
your business either change the business
completely or just restructure your
business so that it allows you to do the
thing that you want to do it's not
taking a break from anything it's not
taking a break on the business or taking
a break from your personal life you
don't want to take a break on life it's
mixed and so everything you do should be
something that you look forward to and
not every absolute thing that's gonna be
crap that you have to deal with but net
like you want to look forward to going
on that business trip you want to look
forward to doing whatever you're doing
in your company today you want to look
forward to what you're doing tonight
when you get home when you see your
husband or wife or significant other
everything is a positive that you're
shooting towards not this at the expense
of that when you wrap your head around
that
when you embrace the and instead of this
or that that's when you start to have
success in happiness
let's go to rule number nine I know I'm
gonna like this one
I believe most people have a belief
about what their real potential is no
matter what you tell them and that
affects how much action they take and of
course that affects the result and then
ironically that result reinforces their
belief and then that belief affects it
so I'll give an example let's say a
person has unlimited potential we all
agree but they take little action little
results why because they have to start
with a problem with their belief they
don't believe it's really gonna happen
for me maybe for Frank Kern's cuz it got
the cool hair and stuff or maybe it's
for you because you're so driven but
it's not me maybe Tony Robbins cuz she's
a freak out these big teeth whatever
their thought process is right they got
this thing right but what happens is if
you believe that there's very little
potential how much action you're gonna
take and when you take a little
potential with a little action what kind
of results you get lousy little results
when you have the results what does that
do to your belief you go see I told you
this was a waste of time soldier this
wouldn't work and then what happens you
tap even less potentially take even less
actually even the worst results in your
belief gets even weaker and this sucker
feeds on itself until you are in a
downward spiral poisonous it's poisonous
and it's self-fulfilling
now what if something could happen that
could come along and fill you with a
sense of absolute certainty not like I
believed but me well you know and you
guys this case mine as well we knew
because we had to because we burned the
boats there was no other option we had
to find a way we had we weren't gonna
live that way we all did it in different
ways and for different reasons but in
that sense that was it if you get
yourself in a state of certainty that
this is gonna work I'm gonna find the
way and if this doesn't work I will make
the way then you tap a lot more
potential than when you're certain your
potential you take massive action when
you take massive action you really
believe in something you get great
results when you get great results your
brain goes see I told you I was a stud I
told you this thing would work out now
you even stronger you have more
potential take greater action be results
that's how you went from 300 bucks in a
week to twenty five hundred and five
days to a hundred thousand and a month
to a million bucks in a day same thing
with you and we get momentum so the rich
get richer the poor get poorer now some
people go out and they go well I'm gonna
take a bunch of action alright I'm gonna
open this product
try it they'll say to you I even did it
but it's like a Salesman it goes and
knocks on the door he knocks on 100
doors and says verbally his face says it
because he doesn't believe it's gonna
work
so his voice his body the execution is
so weak maybe if he talks 200 people
somebody's gonna buy out of pity I'm
gonna win his kids to starve right but
he's not gonna get the result so the
core difference in people is how do you
produce certain day when the world isn't
giving it to you you go out and try and
you try in your case you're a hundred
thousand a debt nothing's working how do
you keep yourself going the way you did
it the way I did it the way you're doing
it we may not done it consciously is we
didn't change our potential that was
there and it wasn't even taking more
action taking more action with beliefs
not gonna works not gonna change
anything we got results in our head that
made us feel certain as if it had
already happened not much to sound this
one I agree Tony Plus believe equals
awesome last point for you guys before
we get to the bonuses number 10 is let
go put your hands on your heart if you
would okay my hands on my heart feel
your heart close your eyes are really
breathing hard those at home could do
the same so they can test this out and
those at home think of something that's
really bothered you I deal with is 7 or
above and you really want to resolve it
and yeah it's gonna be a relationship
situation of business situation kids
whatever breathe in your heart and
actually physically feel your heart feel
it filling with blood and oxygen feel
the beauty of your heart ah yes I'm
getting a heart exam because you get to
hear that it's the strength of your
heart yeah feel the beauty the strength
and through what you're grateful your
heart has guided you to do in this life
so many beautiful things especially you
mm-hmm
and there's your breathing and feeling
that I want you to think of three things
one at a time just for a couple minutes
we'll do a short version here I know you
have a couple minutes but things you're
really grateful for but something that
could be little or big oh but if you
step into that moment you can feel it
right now like you're there yeah yeah
breathe it feel it enjoy it
fill up with it and then they give a
second one that you can feel really
grateful for and see it through your own
eyes as if you were there and really
take it in okay and pick up a third one
find what really you'd really enjoy feel
like it was a blessing such a beautiful
blessing in your life sometimes
coincidences are great because we know
we didn't create them we were guided
right yeah yeah yeah so as you continue
that with your eyes closed breathing
there yeah
and ask yourself about that situation
but stay breathing your heart stay in
that same feeling so you're in a
beautiful state and just ask yourself in
that situation all I need to remember is
all you need to focus on is all I need
to do is what in that situation that was
bothering me breathing in my heart
feeling the same beauty all you need to
remember is calling you to focus on is
the money to believe all I need to do is
what and your heart knows the answer can
you feel it do you know the answer is
appreciate that I'm even in this
position to even have that as a dilemma
yeah yeah and how does that feel now
when you think about it it feels like
gun guys if you just watch that clip I'd
recommend you pause the video go back
and do it again but actually try it
yourself and if you ever feel
overwhelmed by something timestamp that
section of this video and do it because
you'll get a lot more by feeling it
instead of just intellectually thinking
about it and watching it just try it I
promise you you'll feel something it's
worth the rewind to do it again and
actually feel yourself
so thank you guys so much for watching
so many great clips to choose from I
would have to say that rule number nine
is my personal favorite it's believed
it's Tony Robbins please believe what
else am I gonna pick it's the best I
love to know from you though what was
your favorite clip is number nine the
best for you
or is there one that is better for you
that's more immediately applicable to
your life to your business to your
situation let me know down in the
comments below I really want to hear
from you now I made this video because
Subash Limbaugh asked me to so there is
a famous entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next check out the link in
the description you can go leave your
request on the request line and maybe
we'll make it for you soon I also want
to give a quick charter to Sheela
MacArthur Sheela thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word the audible version that was so
much fun to make and thank you for
posting it to your Twitter account as
well I really really really appreciate
it and I hope you enjoyed the book so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
parking lot attendant I have no business
background but I had this passion to
help people and then I was this artist
like a lot of dentists out there and I
wanted to do this beautiful work but I
realized again boy if I don't have a
market and innovate all these ideas are
just gonna die with me
and so I develop those skills and once I
learned how to do that how to be more
for a client than anybody else how to
add more about how to get obsessed about
everything you can do for these people
when you do that you don't have
satisfied customers satisfied customers
go away you are breathing fans and
raving fans stay and reinvest tell
everybody else had really been to it
build your bandwidth grow you
so those things allowed me to grow in my
educational business and then I just
applied those to other businesses there
was a day that I became wealthy I'll
take me a day I know that day I was rich
I was broke I was pissed I was angry at
everybody else but who myself but really
underneath that I was mad at myself
I just couldn't beat myself up anymore
sauce pissed and I had a friend that I
loaned money to and I had barely enough
and I knew he needed it and I gave him
$1,200 and I'm here not able to eat I'm
down to like 25 26 dollars and i'm sandi
am calling him and he's not returning my
call and I just need some money he's
ignoring me I didn't mean ordinance I'm
pissed I'm frustrated in the midst of
all this I'm also pragmatic I got 25 and
changed called $26 what the hell am I
gonna do
I don't have any plans for economics I
got over it that's crazy I'm living this
little tiny apartment for an and square
feet and Miss California so I thought
okay when I was totally broke earlier on
when I'm 17 I used to save my money up
and go to the smorgasbord and load up
for a Christmas you know load up for the
week so I said I was in Venice I'm gonna
go over to Marina del Rey where all the
yachts are in this place they're called
El Torito and I'm gonna go they have an
all-you-can-eat smorgasbord I'm gonna
load up for the winter I'm gonna get
there so I didn't drive there because I
wasn't gonna spend the gas to get there
plus I need the walk so I walked there
and I go in I'm not dressed really great
but Marina del Rey it's okay and I got a
place right by the window I can see
yotz going by and I'm dreaming of what
life could be like and I'm starting to
let go of my anger and I'm starting to
start focus on what I want instead of
what I don't want normally follow say I
and that shifted me just a bit and now
I'm eating what shifted me a lot and I
got this giant plate stacked up and I
don't know what the amount was is like
whatever it was 695 7 95 right so I'm
gonna do this I could probably do this
three or four times right somewhere that
range
cuz I'm finishing my meal this little
boy comes in dressed in a little suit I
honestly don't know how Olli be probably
in the third grade so maybe eight years
old nine years old something like that
and he was so adorable and he opened the
door for his mother as men he was
attractive lady and he came over he pull
out the seat for and she sat down and I
was she was a pretty lady but pretty she
was I was totally obsessed by this boy
he was just he had presence at 7 or 8
years old and it moved me I don't know
why I just it moved me and I thought
this kid is like pure he's I wanted to
always be this way he's such a good kid
he's a giver so I got up and I paid for
the meal and whatever it was six seven
bucks
so now I've got whatever left 17 18 19
dollars and I walk up this little boy I
said excuse me and I said I just want to
acknowledge you for being such an
extraordinary gentleman I said I saw the
way you treated your lady how you open
the door how you pulled the chair out
I said that's class I said my name's
Tony what's yours
they don't honest members named Charlie
or something and he looked up at me and
I said charlie I said that's amazing
taking your date out for a lunch like
this he goes well actually she's my mom
I said that's even more cool and I said
he said oh but I I'm not taking a lunch
cuz I'm just I think he said it was
eight I said oh yes you are
I had no plan for this he's reaching my
pocket I took all the money I had left
17 18 19 dollars and I put on the table
I said you're taking her to lunch he
looked up at me and he goes I can't take
that
I said sure you can he said why cuz I'm
bigger than you are and he smiled real
big and I didn't even look at his mom I
just turned and walked away and I didn't
walk out of that door flew home I should
have been freaking out how am I gonna
eat but I didn't I
flew because something inside of me had
finally got past scarcity and finally
realized there's something inside of us
more than our limits especially on this
thing called money that I had let
terrorize me when I got home and the
mailman came that day and I had no idea
I was gonna have my next meal and if
letter comes and it's from the guy I
loaned the money to handwritten notes
saying I've been avoiding you it's wrong
I'm so sorry you were there when I
needed you
here's what I owe you plus a little bit
more and the twelve hundred there plus
another hundred for the time that I had
to take care of it and for me thirteen
or dollars that was enough to like run
my show for a month or two and I cried
and then I decided what does this mean
but I thought this means that whenever
you give it's always gonna come back so
you don't have to ever think about that
but again just give and the rewards be
great and you can ever imagine I don't
know if that's coincidence but I decided
to believe that day was the blessing
when I became rich and I can tell you
honestly I've had tough days in my life
economically emotionally like all of us
but I've never gone back to the scarcity
I never will
the secret to living is giving do it
when you don't have it and I promise you
scarcity will leave your life raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that mm-hmm
that people need passion and not one
drop of most self-worth depends on your
it's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most of success I have
a very special secret video for you
these are the individual clips that I
have personally learned the most from
and applied to my life and my business
check the link the description for
details